[Music]
the patriarchy has become a powerful
feminist watchword for the unequal
division of power between men and women
in some fields though the tables have
turned with women 1/3 more likely to go
to university 3/4 of teachers being
women and the courts predominantly
giving women custody of children should
we be demanding equality for men in
these areas or other arenas where
equality is a mistaken goal and women
should have the upper hand
now on the panel on my right is Jonah
Williams dr. Johnny Williams is the
author of women vs feminism associate
editor of the political magazine spiked
and head of educational culture at
policy exchange Phillip blonde on my
left is a political philosopher anglican
theologian and director of the raised
public a think-tank is the author of red
Tory how left and right have broken
Britain and how we can fix it and join
us joining us on the left of the
platform is Elif sorry cam she's a
Kurdish rights activist she's coming to
the festival shortly after visiting or
java in northern Syria where the Kurdish
liberation movement has established a
unique political system based on direct
democracy and which is ideologically
feminist well let's start with those
first statements for three minutes and
does the patriarchy exist Jonah Williams
does it did it no yes I know I don't
think the patriarchy does exist anymore
I think it's meaningless to talk about
patriarchy in society today and I think
you can look at that from two different
perspectives
the first is literally in terms of men
are men dominating positions of power
are men males running society are men
keeping women are in a subservient
position in society today and to me the
answer to all of those questions is no
but I think patriarchy means something
beyond just men and male dominance I
think
also can be associated with their
distinct set of values and for me I
think this is the most important shift
that's taken place in society over the
past two or three decades where if you
think of values that were traditionally
associated with a patriarchal society or
male dominance so I'm thinking of things
like stoicism stiff upper-lip a kind of
emotional strength almost an aggression
perhaps a competitive competitiveness
ambition I I don't think these are
exclusively male values I think females
can embody these values just as much I
hope I have some of those values I would
aspire to have some of those values but
I think they were a set of values that's
traditionally been associated with
masculinity traditionally emerged from a
patriarchy if you like and I think far
more even than men being taken out of
positions of power and replaced by women
I think we've had a cultural shift and a
values shift away from those values
where these values are actually seen as
being quite negative nowadays so if you
think of the word masculinity the the
word that's most often used in
conjunction with masculinity nowadays is
toxic we talk about toxic masculinity if
you think that having a stiff upper lip
or being stoic in the face of adversity
is good nowadays and actually you're
seen as having a psychological problem
that you should probably get counseling
for because you're not in touch enough
with your emotions you're not sensitive
enough and I think the values that
dominate in society nowadays are far
more values that would traditionally be
associated with the feminine so a need
to be sensitive to be caring to not have
a stiff upper lip but to be prepared and
happy to talk about your emotions so I
think you can look at patriarchy in two
different ways
a tally of males and females but also I
think far more fundamentally a value and
it's that value shift that makes me
think that we do not
live in a society that's a patriarchy
anymore but actually out the opposite so
it's fluid blonde and does patriarchy
exist no I don't I don't think it does
in that scale in the West anymore
did it perhaps and we can certainly talk
about that what I think we live in now
is is quite a much more dangerous world
and the deployment of things like
patriarchy or patriarchy is a sensual
way of vilifying men to call so that we
produce an account that says basis of
your white male heterosexual who are
almost by definition an oppressor that
you have no liberating or emancipatory
ability or outcome and it's a strange
sort of inverted fascism really against
1/2 of of of the human race broadly
speaking and it's deeply problematic
because what it advances is an insidious
liberal feminist project that destroys
solidarity the hallmark of radical
politics now is an anti solidarity
project so that we reduce all of our
human concerns and all of our wishes for
a better life to sectional groups be
they black be they gay be they women and
we vilify all other groups and we
destroy the idea of common value sets
and common solidarity which is alone is
the condition from which we can
emancipate all and this is part I think
of a genuinely dangerous nihilistic come
fascist trend in our society that I
think will lead to very extreme politics
of the future and also I think it's very
clear that women at least in the West
are doing very well and liberal feminism
which is the dominant they're not the
only form of feminism is essentially a
way of upper-mid
class women advancing their high status
yet further buyers Johanna argues
rightly in my view claiming victimhood
and in victimhood is the new middle
class coinage for self advancement and
that's the the point it's an upper class
language game that ignores class and
ignores solidarity with with other women
who aren't in in such an advanced class
position so it's somewhat revolting what
we really need and what I'd really
advocate for is a radical feminism and
that needs something like a return to
essentialism a recognition that men and
women are really different that they're
not the same and that justice isn't
about imposing a false neutrality a
transgender fiction upon real and
essential differences justice is really
about how do we cater for those
differences such that people don't pay a
price for them so if you look at
something like okay I'll probably and I
think you've got the general drift I
think that is probably sufficiently
provoked it yes by a few things Elif
sorry can I just the patriarchy exist
I mean firstly wow I I personally and
I'm taking my jacket off for this I
personally find the question of whether
patriarchy exists or not quite insulting
firstly because I mean I come from I so
I'm Kurdish as was said in the
introduction I come from the place where
you know according to the historical
references we have is the birthplace of
patriarchy you know from the beginning
of the Sumerian state and and so on so
where I come from we know very well the
effects of patriarchy now I know that I
know the distinction is between being
made in some of the friends who are
speaking here between whether it did
exist and does it still exist or not but
I think you know when we talk about a
quote-unquote vilifying of
a group of people of course that
shouldn't happen but I think there's a
difference between pointing out
privilege and vilification and I think
if we start equating to the two with
each other I think we that's when we get
into dangerous territory and I think
again it's quite a historical injustice
to call pointing out you know white male
privilege equating that to fascism
fascism has caused the death of millions
of people I haven't seen the weather if
it is the vilification or pointing out
privilege I haven't seen that cause the
mass genocide of white men just yet and
I hope obviously it never happens but
you know so I think when when we talk
about the patriarchy we're not just
talking about individual men of course
it's not like obviously there's there's
about you know four billion men on in
the world it doesn't mean you know four
billion men are all or all patriarchs of
course that doesn't mean that patriarchy
is about a system of dominance it's a
structure of dominance and therefore
it's a system that is built around
particular ideas that still exists and
you know I know again the distinction is
made between the Western and the non
West again as though us in the West are
always more further ahead and
progressive than the non West which
obviously is just factually incorrect
and you know we need to understand that
but even in the West if we still have
the question of the controller over
women's body is being discussed
that's a structure of patriarchy if the
discussion of women whether women should
be able to have the right to be able to
abort or terminate a pregnancy or not is
still being discussed that is a
structure of patriarchy by definition
because it's its dominance over women's
bodies in that sense and you know when
we talk about you know I think
potentially Joanne has a very specific
experience in life in general and I
can't say much to that experience
obviously because I simply don't have
that experience but I think we really
need to be able to understand that
sometimes it's not that our experiences
the majority but in fact it's the
minority experience in a sense where you
know most most people you know
individual women may be in very high
positions in other you know certain job
sectors or or so on and as Philip said
you know parts of society especially if
your middle or middle class or above but
I think you know there's women who and
I'm sure in this room who are still
getting paid less for doing the exact
same job and having the exact same
qualification for with their male
colleagues this is a system of
patriarchy and it doesn't mean there's
these like evil like older white men in
a room like you know plotting these all
the time obviously not but it is a
system that came about through men and
men and male dominance building this now
and again of course there's women who
are patriarchs as well because this
isn't like I said this is more of a
system and a mentality than a gender or
a sex issue perhaps now but I guess you
know we can talk about you know because
you wanted to ask about the specific
experience well no no no I think there's
about 10 or 12 things we could follow up
sure you've just said and but I think
there may be a problem here in that you
know which we seem to be generalizing
about humanity as a whole and then we're
dealing with so many different parts of
the world when so many different things
apply we haven't talked we talked about
essentially a non secular world we
haven't talked about the patriarchy is
that may or may not exist within more
religiously inclined societies and so
for the purpose of this first part of
the discussion can we focus on what we
might call well this country and then I
would like to talk to you specifically
there's a bit later about your
experience in the Middle East but let's
just focus in this country so are we
talking about here we're talking
essentially when we talk about
patriarchy we're talking about power and
more power automatically being given to
men because of their sex than anything
else and you would argue would you for a
lot of people that this is still we're
making maybe maybe making most forwards
away from that society but we are still
broadly a patriarchal society I think
that would be now Phillip you challenge
that yeah yeah I think this is just
nonsense I'm afraid and in this in this
now let me let me speak to it so the the
pay gap is overwhelmingly a pregnancy
gap
in all the studies that's been done of
gently I appreciate you how to read the
literature but I have and so so in all
the studies that have been done on the
pay gap it's overwhelmingly a pregnancy
gap yes we should why should hold on in
which case why should women be penalized
for getting pregnant
exactly and that's because the feminism
that we've had has been patriarchal
because the type of feminism liberal
feminism that we've advanced was the
feminism or autonomy that didn't
recognize that women have children and
also the overwhelming majority want to
care for those children and the pay gap
is up to the age of 30 women with
degrees have higher wages than men with
degrees women women women out-compete
man in all forms of education up to and
including university level now in and
the pregnancy pay gap is essentially the
pay gap is essential because we haven't
provided for women who have children at
the scale needed and when women have
children they come they move out of the
workforce when they come back they're on
a non career pathway they're at a lower
rate and they part-time suitor so in
society which is made for men as hasn't
adjusted to the reality of know what
actually happened is the type of
feminism that took legislative form was
a patriarchal type that didn't account
for for feminists for the difference of
women and the difference of women
bearing and having children I am more
feminist I would argue precise because I
want that to be catered for so you're
contradicting yourself that you're
saying is I'm not a patriarchy because I
want to alter what is still a
patriarchal system so you've just
acknowledged in advance of your own case
that the system is still based on kids
often I have said I have said that the
patriarchy that has emerged is that is
stale dominant is primarily a possession
of liberal feminism because liberal
feminism listen to this liberal feminism
advances autonomy then the nature where
women are blocked is when they are non
autonomous and the prime point when
non-autonomous is when they have
children and that was advanced by the
liberal feminism that emerged in the
1960s what I'm saying is as a more
radical feminist than that type of offer
the great danger is liberal feminism if
we really want to be radical feminists
we have to cater for the difference that
women have and when in possess and the
trouble is is most liberal feminism
doesn't do this at a point to point to
hold on I was told you on this point
because there are too many points being
but I forgive me what you've seem to be
advocating as far as I understand it is
one a patriarchy did exist too in our
society the results of that are still
evident three your solution is a
different form of feminism but it
doesn't deny the fact that the vestiges
if you like of that patriarchy are still
existing and are still pertinent and
affecting people so you know right sorry
two or three right Janet
and so um just to come back to you the
points that were raised down here and
some of the things that the audience so
if we look at law for example I think
law is a really good example of how far
society has changed in recent years so
60% 60% of lawyers are now female in
MAGIX are coal companies which as you
know are at the top the very very top
law firms 47% are female so gender
equality okay
so again I don't have the exact
statistics right but it's the other
argument that sorry because if this is
the argument charter there that the
innocent because the figures are so
large now for the numbers of women
joining the profession you believe that
it is inevitable as they move up that
the higher reaches men will because
women will become partners more dominant
in other words there's a necessary time
lag I think that's definitely true I do
believe that I think society's changed
so quickly and of course this new
entrants come in from the bottom up it
does begin to have a change but then it
is the case that people women and men
don't live in the world we don't live in
gender exclusive bubbles
I don't just live with
women I live with a partner with my
children that are both male and female I
work with male and female colleagues we
don't live in these kind of gender
exclusive bubbles in our society we work
alongside each other we live alongside
each other and people in families men
and women together do make choices about
what they want to do when they have
children how they want to organize their
lives now we can be critical of other
people's choices often people are but we
don't make those choices for people but
your honor the argument is that actually
by virtue of being a woman there's only
one choice you all not only one choice
you are more likely to have to take a
certain choice than another in other
words choice is theoretically there but
in fact by the nature of the structure
Society is far more limited for women
than for men so you can make a
theoretical grace but in a practical
case it is not the case
the choices are loaded more towards men
than women you dispute that now well I
think actually if you work in a law firm
particularly if you work in a top law
firm if you have a decent salary as a
lawyer the choices that are available to
you as a woman or as a man are way more
extensive than the choices that would be
available to you if you work on the
checkout in a supermarket if you work as
a cleaner if you have a low wage what
empowers people to be able to make these
choices in life is money and that's the
bottom line
the more money you have the more ability
you have to be able to say well I'll
work a few days a week I work part-time
you know I'll organize my life how I
want to the less money you have the more
difficult it is to be able to make these
choices the problem is feminism by very
definition forces us to see the world
through gender lights to see the world
as men on have you made a pretty a
latest case for university educated
women with a vast range of middle-class
choices not available to working-class
women exactly this is the problem I
would like these choices to be available
to more women iron tube to all women to
all women and men but I don't think we
so so we have complete gender equality
in terms of pay for people who were in
minimum-wage jobs if you work in a care
home a supermarket as a cleaner you're
going to get the minimum way
and that minimum wage is the same
whether you are a man or a woman exactly
and this is why I'm not advocating it at
all and this is why I'm saying that if
we focus exclusively on something like
the gender pay gap then yep great
so Rwanda for example um is fourth in
the world league tables for gender
equality because men and women have
equally little we can have minimum wage
zero gender pay gap actually that's not
great I'd far rather live in a world
where men and women earned more than the
minimum wage and were able to make
better life choices different life
choices because because they had the
money and the freedom to be able to do
that when we focus myopically on gender
we do risk a race to the bottom Elif so
I mean just to make clear I have read
literature and I have analyzed
especially being a part of the Kurdish
women's movement I have an Alaia Dan
alysus analyses of 5000 years of the
history of civilization so I've read
this - I've read about the Neolithic era
where it was more of a what we could
call not necessarily a matriarchy but a
with women oriented society and many of
the things we take for granted actually
you know because the discussion around
you know women having children and then
therefore you know forgetting about
their careers and so on this is
obviously an incredibly essentialist
approach and I know you're deliberately
being an essentialist you advocating for
that and I understand that but this is
this is what creates the division
actually you know we talk about feminism
and don't get me wrong
I am with the radical feminism that I
don't know what rabbit achill feminism
that you maybe you may want to advocate
but I'm a part of a radical feminist
movement I'm part of the movement that
defeated Isis women defeated Isis and
our building in northern Syria a society
that is based on direct democracy
gender liberation and ecology so this is
the movement I'm part of and it's
happening it's happening in northern
Syria is happening in a part of the
world's where most people in this room
about ten years ago wouldn't have
imagined it would happen but it was able
to happen because of the analysis of the
reality of patriarchy and male dominance
the analysis is based on that in
conjunction with class with capitalism
with colonialism with imperialism and
all of these intertwined now again
there's obviously just flesh this out a
little bit short so the decision may
well long may it continue but the
decision-making the constitution that
you agree amongst yourselves who's done
that and what do you say for example
about participation do you have quotas
do you have insist together how do you
implement so that in the structure of
your emerging society so the way it
works is the society right now is is
organized on the you know the foundation
of it are assemblies people's assemblies
and the way they work is every assembly
has a co-chair system so there's a man
and a woman who chair these assemblies
and there's a minimum forty percent
quota for women in every single level of
administration and there's also
autonomous women's structures that have
veto power over any decision that is
made for society and this is this exists
again like I said because that is
because of the very real understanding
of patriarchy and how that is
intertwined with climate it's also pop
because in a sense you it's a
revolutionary situation you have swept
away a clear and hopefully for a long
time what existed so you can build from
virtually it's clear ground whereas what
we're looking at yeah it's societies
which are have evolved the ones we're in
maybe we need a revolution either here
in much more complex way over a longer
period and it's simply not possible to
make the sort of break that you've made
yeah no I I mean of course there's a
reality here there's a fully functioning
well in some ways functioning government
there but there is a government there is
a state and so there's also proposals
and suggestions of how that can happen
within an existing straight state
structure so there's so there's
suggestions for municipal municipal ism
which i think is is becoming what a
wider discussion hopefully in in our
country and also other aspects of
people's assemblies whether it's you
know local trying to organize and
somehow make use of the local power that
still remains you know whether it's
within councils awards or and so on but
I think you know we need when we talk
about patriarchy you know I think it's
really patronizing to constantly try and
use quite pseudo-scientific
so-called statistics or studies if there
are those that either scientific
statistics or not if the studio we will
problem what are you suggesting that the
gentleman on my left uses to do
statistics I don't he may not
deliberately be using them but I think
the studies really tell me what is
especially the pregnancy aspect because
one not all women actually have children
- there there are women who just simply
can't have children you know take your
medicine and allegation I mean I don't
want to talk about statistics because I
don't believe in statistics prescience
Tudors because I just think we shouldn't
be making grand decisions and
suggestions about systems based on micro
statistics that's the point I'm trying
to make which is why I'm not trying to
give an alternative statistic I'm
talking about you know qualitative
real-life things and people around us
and especially if we want to talk about
the UK I think most of us have a right
let me I must move on to the first point
here so we picked it up is the question
that seemed about whether men have to
lose out for women to gain equality and
I think the implication of some things
from the audience is that it men are in
such a privileged position that although
we have greater opportunity for women
that a long way for equality and
actually it means in part
then having to lose out through injeolmi
quality there's anybody on the platform
think that's the case but many in a
sense have to accept the responsibility
for the past and restrict accept
prescriptions in order to go forward
does anybody accept that no I don't
accept it but I want to look at some
things that have happened historically
which perhaps showed that this is the
case to some extent so the gender pay
gap
I do like statistics I'm afraid I'm not
going to go into the intricacy of the
gender statistics here and now but but
you know I can do and I might do a
little bit I think everybody in the room
here no matter whether you think the
gender pay gap is at 18% which that's an
average which takes all men and all
women it's not a median hourly pay gap
if you look at the median hourly so
compare the hourly rate and the median
hourly rate it comes down to eight point
nine percent and that's office for
national statistics not just me making
it up but but I hope everybody in this
room whatever you think the gender pay
gap might be agrees that it has come
down so both that we think it's a huge
25 percent or whether we think it's a 1
percent or whatever it has come down
dramatically but you think it should be
eradicated but but the point is we now
have to ask why as the gender pay gap
come down is it because women are just
doing so much better and earning so much
more well for some women yes that is the
case you know with the expansion of
higher education we've got more women
nowadays working as accountants doctors
lawyers vets you know women have really
entered the professions in a way that 20
30 years ago just was not the case at
the same time you go up to places like
Middlesbrough where I'm from in the
northeast of England and the steelworks
the chemical plants the jobs that
traditionally men were doing that were
high paid jobs decent paid jobs have
collapsed this is a long term thing
going back to the factory government of
the 70s and the 80s so the gender pay
has balanced out as well in these old
industrial heartlands not because women
have been doing so much spectacularly
better but because their high paid men's
jobs of mining industry have gone so
then you open up new jobs for people
supermarkets cold centers equally badly
paid for men and women now my concern
with the discussion about patriarchy and
feminism as I've kind of the point I've
been making all along really is that by
impeaching men and women against each
other as this zero-sum game I've a women
where no men lose or men win and women
lives you stop being able to fight for
what's better for everyone which would
be better paid jobs better more industry
new economic investment so that both men
and women have the opportunity to earn
more get a better quality life for
themselves I Pro found me agree with all
that and I think if we if we look at the
core news the OECD intra country
inequality is now higher than intra
country inequality so inequalities are
higher within a country than between
countries which is a remarkable change
and Eva women on women just general it
general inequality so if you are
interested in justice for all the type
of politics we have cannot deliver that
and the type of politics that we have
which is sectional politics segregating
people off and pursuing particular
interests liberal emancipatory politics
do not deliver and if you're interested
in the rise of populism and the rise of
the West it's largely a pushback against
social and economic liberalism that
fragments people and doesn't deliver for
the bottom half and increasingly you'll
soon be the bottom 60% of society so if
you're interested in general
emancipation we need different forms and
different ways to argue against
discrimination so you basically want
socialism
I want a form of collective care for
everybody and I think there's then
there's
sumit difference between how we achieve
that so what I wanted to suggest to you
is the way we've been trying to advance
black people gay people women bla bla
bla is fundamentally wrong and cannot
deliver on that general good and part of
what I think evinces this is if you look
at the current kind of war within
feminism between what one might call sex
and gender and and the transsexual count
because the type of capitalism or the
type of extreme liberalism that I think
we need to oppose is the type that
essentially individualizes us and strips
us of our difference to such an extent
that we can't cater for that difference
and make that difference equal with
other differences so in gender women are
looking at the erasure of their own
spaces are looking at the erasure of the
very idea of distinction the very idea
of women are essentially being removed
by transsexual type arguments so you're
getting an account that wants to take
the whole of women out of the equation
so you can't even have with feminism
because there's no such thing as women
because there's no sir because
everything is gender and everything is
flux that's why I want to argue for
essentialism and I think that what we
need to recover before you argue for it
would you explain what it is okay
essentialism would be something like
squaring with the reality that men and
women exist as distinct biological
social cultural forms and they really
are different and the project of social
justice which I believe in is about how
those people don't pay a penalty for the
differences they have that's the new
project which will require in my view a
different type of feminism than the one
we currently have I just finished two
more minutes no no sorry one more minute
because what we have seen if we really
care about justice the most oppressed
groups in the UK are white working-class
males they are the people who pay the
highest penalty they are the people who
have a brain migrant women who know
actually
not really it isn't it really isn't it
really isn't why do you argue from
anecdotal positions but actually on the
bet on all the evidence that's been
presented white market working class
males pay the highest penalty and here's
the two indicators that determine you
the place of your birth and the level of
your mother's education out-compete
every other indicator for what will
happen to you that that's clap we need a
separate session on essentialism and
class and whatever and now just what it
would forgive me for just going back to
the first theme I want to give you one
example which I think encapsulates the
dilemma when we talk about do men have
to lose out for women to gain equality
you may have noticed this big round
weather where a woman appointed as
deputy editor in BBC News has refused to
take up the job because she was offered
a serve less I think about traditionally
12,000 less than a man the other deputy
appointed and lots of women the bieber's
he signed up in her support and maybe
she said same job same rate of pay the
problem is that the BBC doesn't have a
rate of pay for a job it has a band and
in that band what you get paid is
weighted also by the length of time you
spent in the organization and to agree
your age so the man she is up against
has edited number programs is 58 and so
on so in order if you take the view that
that doesn't matter it's the rate for
the job taking of the BBC at the moment
what you'll have to do is bring the
man's pay down and say there's no longer
a band for a job there's a rate but it
also means however long you do it have a
lawyer arts that company you not get any
more money because there is a rate for
the job that seems to me to encapsulate
a real dilemma I just wanted to mention
it because you know the way it's report
is slightly different so if you take one
view men will have to be penalized if
you take another and the primary thing
is equality of pay the pay is the job
the pay that determines it you take
another into those dilemmas that have
been fort house so I think they think
and we see the overall issue of women's
pay at the BBC making news headlines
time and time again to me this two shows
really good illustration of how
middle-class feminism is if you work in
McDonald's and you go for a job
interview in McDonald's and you say oh
I'd like to negotiate my salary please
and I'd like my experience and I'd like
my reputation to be taken into account
they're laughing you they say there's a
job we'll get somebody else thank you if
you're a teacher even which is a fairly
middle-class job if you're a teacher and
you say I'd like to negotiate my salary
I'd like this and this to be taken into
account they say no this is the pay
scale this is what you get we've had
equal pay legislation in this country
and the same job same pay for many
decades since the mid 1970s and any
woman sitting in this room now if you
think that you are doing the exact same
job at the exact same level for the
exact same number of hours each week as
a man and are being paid differently
you need to seek legal redress that's
really important because you're your
employer is breaking the law and you
should go and get legal redress and I
will help you if you know make this
offer available I will do my best to
help you however when it comes to the
BBC Hollywood advertising some of these
industries that very few people work in
where where honestly I look at them and
their salaries to me look like telephone
numbers it's a salary which is way
beyond my wildest imaginings and the
wildest imaginings of everybody I know
in my family I just try to preserve
pictures then you know I'm sorry but my
heart doesn't really bleed and their
salaries are not based on the same rate
the same way in which my salary is
negotiated it's their reputation their
ability to pull in an audience they're
experienced negotiators through ages
yeah when they need to get a better age
yeah but I think you're mistaking
performance as opposed to produce this
know this because the BBC pay levels
generative count for ordinary write down
and what's happened with the
fragmentation in the industry is that
particularly and it tends been really a
lot of women are in short term contracts
salaries haven't gone up it's
casualisation they haven't been paid for
long time but no man that's the side can
we I just wanted to get the second theme
here which is other arenas where
equality is a mistaken girl and when
should have the upper hand let me ask
the provocative question which is I
suppose on this is it the case that
women have to be or should be or we
should assume they should have the
primary rights when it comes to children
we've heard the assertion here in terms
of abortion that essentially and it's on
an issue of life like that it is a
woman's decision do you extend that into
life itself and do we say outside of
business there is a fundamental if you
like era where equality is mistaken
because women should be given primacy in
terms of children and childcare not that
they must but that's a fundamentalist
assumption they should have that right
do you have any any sympathy for that
perspective I mean I think this question
is very intertwined with like the
previous question as well in terms of do
men have to lose out for women to be
equal I think I don't think it's that
different I mean my true answer would be
no you know I think in in the case of a
child a custody situation you know I
think that's one of the one of the
arenas where the individual case is
really important because it doesn't mean
just because you're a woman you're just
naturally going to be a great mother
right absolutely not breakups let's look
at families that stay together should it
be assumed that in that power structure
the woman should be the dominant figure
when it comes to the upbringing of
children those decisions I certainly do
you be other you would argue for
equality of that yeah I think so too I
think that's pretty important but but
but you don't do it on abortion even
though there that's the woman
individually herself carrying that they
don't share but the manicott but yeah
but the man has had a role and the child
has an independent life I'm not sure
that they'll say women is to separate I
should have the dominant view but then
you arguing exclusively about abortion
you know yeah for sure okay I feel this
case but can I just make this point I
think this case is of course you know if
you're if you have a partner if you're I
think yeah I think most of the time it
you know it usually is a mutual decision
but I think the ultimate decision to
terminate literally growing life within
you should be up to the person so it's
like decide try and forgive me I I went
on the side rack on the question of
abrupt beggining of children that should
we accept that women should have the the
dominant decision-making role not that
they should share the work if you like
but the decision-making should propose
only the woman I mean I think that's
entirely down to individual families in
their own situations I mean I'll be
perfectly honest I've got three children
and I would not be sat here today if my
husband wasn't at home looking after
them you know and that's not something
we don't sit down and bring out a
spreadsheet and say well you know I've
had five days this week you know me
looking after them so you've got five
days next week you just negotiate things
as you go along I don't know any family
where they bring out a spreadsheet and
people Talia some people would say that
is a naturally stronger in the early
years relationship between a mother
children that in those circumstances a
woman God has two but we should expect a
woman to take a leap more leading role
perhaps later on the balance changes is
that some of you I don't think that and
maybe I'm just revealing my own terrible
motherhood here but I think I'm really
with a leaf on this you know when I had
children I don't think a kind of magic
maternal instinct clicked in my brain
immediately not so I don't love my
children if they're watching or
recording of this I love them very much
indeed but it's not like you know
hormonal II I have some different
chemical structure in my body that makes
me naturally superior as a parents my
husband in many ways I think he's a
better parent than I am in relation to
our children and I think our you know
society does put women into that
position so for example if my children
are ill at school if our children are
ill at school it will often be the case
that the school phones me up and I'll
laugh and I'll say well I'm sorry I'm
200 miles away have you thought of
phoning my husband ever who happens to
be at home but I think more and more
this is the case now again sorry to
bring it back to statistics but there is
no huge gap in men and women being
employed outside of
the home it's pretty down near equal
between the numbers of women and men who
have jobs so the idea that the school
would phone up women to say you know
apologize for not pursuing the very
large number of other issues that came
out here apologizes we haven't got more
time they're like on your behalf to
thank the panelists for not holding back
in any way thank you very much for
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institute of arts and ideas
at AI TV
you